unfortunately a very very impactful day
we have some Dreadful news to share with
you our defending Champion
has withdrawn from the tournament due to
illness Tony Rich the executive director
of the St Louis chess club is with
Almera to explain how this will impact
our tournament over to you Elmira oh yes
hello yes sir hello Nazi I'm joined in
the studio by Tonya Rich the executive
director of the Saint Louis chess club
Tonya this is a very unusual situation
please tell us how does it impact the
tournament sure you know it's
unfortunate when any player has to
withdraw from an event and as he also
mentioned due to illness humpy notified
us last night that she had to withdraw
from the 2023 Cairns cup now the fide
regulations are pretty clear on events
especially around Robin events when a
player withdraws the regulations state
that if a player withdraws before the
halfway point and since this was round
four out of nine it was before the
halfway point of the tournament in cases
where a player withdraws before that
halfway point all of their previous
results are annulled and all of their
future opponents get a rest day instead
of playing them on the day they would
have played them so essentially it turns
this into a tournament of nine players
instead of a tournament of 10 players
okay thank you Tony this was a very
clear explanation and yes sir would you
be so kind to explain us how does it
affect the standings absolutely thank
you Tony thank you Almera indeed it's
very very impactful on the standings
because just around previously
uh Alexander was in first place not any
longer and Nasi do the honors